montréal n'est plus en reste des grandes
villes du monde
elle est touchée à son tour par la
frénésie de l'immobilier depuis janvier
le prix des immeubles augmente quatre
fois plus vite que le coût de la vie
21 trimestres de hausse de suite dans le
marché résidentiel de montréal
est ce qu'on a déjà vu ça mais une
enquête révèle à quel point cette
opportunité en or pour les investisseurs
deux plaques fait complètement faussé la
coller des offres multi est devenu un
cauchemar
s'ils se sont toutes cette vidéo ici
pour les locataires qui en subissent le
contrecoup
ça va être qu'il prochains acheteurs qui
va arriver puis qui va décider de sortir
tout le monde parce que finalement il
peut faire un peu d'argent
le logement est un droit de plus en plus
mener si c'est que le logement est
traitée comme une marchandise ou il ya
pas d'humains à l'intérieur c'est juste
un objet de spéculation
[Musique]
propriétaire prêteurs courtiers ils
étaient plus de 800 réunis récemment à
montréal
attirés par les promesses exceptionnelle
de l'immobilier outillés pour doper le
marché une économie robuste une poussée
migratoire et une pénurie de logements
qui frôle la crise
l'effervescence touche autant les
grandes tours d'habitation la
construction de neuf que les plex qui
font le caractère si particulier de
montréal
toute cette section le ceto des condos
et les puits de la quadrette ici
énormément de reno vision c'est fou ce
team bleu un immeuble de six logements
est mis tout le monde dehors transformé
ça qu'on doit exhiber martin blanchard
est en première ligne ou comité logement
de la petite-patrie
le logement est d'abord un chez soi le
locataire paie un loyer convenable
propriétaire fournit un service adéquat
on n'est pas là dedans le quand on parle
de marchandisation et de
financiarisation on est faut faire de
l'argent le plus vite possible
alarmé par la hausse des plaintes qui
ont triplé en deux ans le comité
logement a décidé d'enquêter des cas de
reprise et d'éviction
c'était laborieux en termes de travail
en termes de ressources
jamais un lac à table
montréal est une exception canada avec
près de la moitié de ménages locataires
ce sont eux qui paient le prix de
l'engouement pour l'immobilier
selon louise gaudreault professeur à
l'uqam les gens qui achètent dans le
marché à la hausse
sand est plus que jamais et sont
entraînés dans une spirale la pression
qui s'exerce heureux pour rembourser
leur prêt hypothécaire
on y compterait à se tourner vers le
qatar pour soit augmenter les loyers ou
souhaitent essayer de les remplacer par
des gens qui pourraient payer plus cher
le droit de propriété de pouvoir rénover
son immeuble
la corporation des propriétaires
immobiliers trouve que ce sont les
loyers qui ne montrent pas assez vite
pour absorber les coûts de rénovation
les le parc immobilier locatif la été
construit surtout dans les années 50 60
des rénovations majeures doivent sont
nécessaires pour relouer des locataires
dans certains cas plus cher c'est vrai
mais est-ce qu'on est mieux que
l'immeuble tombe qu'on reconstruise des
cours d'eau mais il y à des
propriétaires il y à des spéculateurs
des gens qui ont l'air de façon très
assumé pour l'argent les des
spéculateurs qui font qu'ils achètent
dans le but de transformer rapidement
puis de revendre rapidement à tout prix
mélinda a porté plainte contre son
propriétaire à la régie du logement et
l'habitat rue bélanger
ça fait des mois qu'elle est forcé de
laver sa vaisselle dans sa baignoire
alors c'est ce que savent pas si c'est
là la pièce multifonctions salle de
bains espace de nettoyage vaisselle
litière et le problème vielles de la
plomberie de sa cuisine
j'étais en train de force de lavage plat
tout d'un coup ça s'est mis à gicler au
bord du tuyau lol l'avare offert en plus
évident est le propriétaire lui a
demandé de partir mais melinda vit avec
son fils à quelques pas de l'école
qu'ils fréquentent à 900 dollars
son logement est un des rares encore
abordables dans le quartier
la loi lui permet de rester alors ils
exigent que la plomberie soit réparé
glisser dans ma porte je reçois une
réponse à ma mise en demeure qui dit que
que j'ai pas le droit de toucher à rien
puis en plus j'ai une éviction qui dit
qu'il faut que je parte parce qu'il me
subdiviser le logement
le propriétaire dit maintenant vouloir
transformer les six logements neufs
logement julie qui habite l'étagé du
dessous depuis plus de dix ans est sous
le choc
mais on est surpris fâché démunis on a
beaucoup beaucoup de questions dans ce
sens où est ce que j'ai vraiment pas
choix est ce qui est vraiment un endroit
où je m'envole d'autres quartiers
rapporte la même hausse marquée de
locataires qui craignent de se faire
évincer sous de faux prétextes d un
phénomène en pleine explosion dans les
cartes comme le plateau mont royal un
sud-ouest de montréal où les thons
d'inoccupation frôle à peu près les 0%
en ce moment
mon client est un contexte qui favorise
ces pressions que vivent les locataires
plusieurs quartiers voit l'apparition
croissante d'un autre type de
propriétaire georgette rébillon vie au
centre ville depuis trente ans son
immeuble a été acquis en 2015 par cap 8
un des plus grands fonds de placement
immobilier au canada et depuis elle se
bat pour faire respecter ses droits
j'ai n'ai jamais eu de problèmes de
chauffage depuis qu'ils sont arrivés ça
chauffe plus parce que vous allez vous
plaindre au bas la réponse est on n'y
peut rien c'est toronto qui gère le
chauffage à toronto comme à montréal des
locataires se sont plaints de problèmes
semblables dans d'autres immeubles de
4,8
madame rébillon a vraiment l'impression
que le propriétaire réduit les dépenses
le plus possible c'est pas difficile
nous ont ils ont tous eu trait mais ils
ont supprimé le une scène qui faisait le
ménage finement une fois par semaine ils
ont supprimé le peintre et ils ont
supprimé le garder à nice
capri tu as enregistré une performance
record en 2019
les appartements ça rapporte comme
l'entreprise se plaît à le dire dans des
rapports à ses actionnaires
la fonction d' infondées vis d'un fonds
de placement immobilier d'un ruitz et de
générer de la rampe pour des
actionnaires c'est des gestionnaires des
gestionnaires qui ont pour principale
tâche de justement ou mental augmenter
la valeur du portefeuille
montréal est maintenant dans la mire de
plusieurs grands fonds de placement
immobilier
ils ont effectué plusieurs milliards de
dollars d'acquisitions dans la métropole
ces deux dernières années dans les
quartiers comme la petite patrie la
spéculation immobilière prendre d'autres
formes
l'anc est mené par le comité logement
révèle que le phénomène des rénovations
et des démos fiction où poussent les
locataires à la porte a pris une ampleur
qui dépasse tout ce qu'il imaginait nos
conclusions de nos enquêtes sur 4 ha
de travail sur 362 unités
c'est que 80 5% de ses 362 unités de
logements ont fait l'objet d'une fraude
ou d'une malveillance
on n'en revient pas de l'ampleur c'est
que ce soit systématique dans 22% des
cas on se serait débarrassé des
locataires sous de faux prétextes pour
relouer plus cher au ventre 62% des cas
serait de la malveillance
la tentative d'éviction de reprise
auraient échoué mais les locataires sont
partis à force d'usure
ce qui fait dire à martin blanchard que
si la loi est si souvent contourné ce
qu'il est facile de le faire
en fait cette invitation à la fraude
la manière dont les lois sont faites
dont le droit est appliquée
c'est un aveuglement complet à toutes
les fraudes et la malveillance que l'on
voit en matière de logements qui sont
utilisés pour la spéculation
l'intérêt qu'on porte en ce moment au
marché immobilier tout l'optimisme qu'on
a quand à la halle à 11 h p des valeurs
et cetera
les prix fait en sorte que de plus en
plus d'incitatifs de contourner les
règles en place
la transformation d'appartements en
condos les locations court terme de type
airbnb et les flip très populaire on va
en plus on va faire un flop sont des
opportunités d'affaires qui répondent
souvent à la même logique spéculative
mais qui aggrave la pénurie de logements
rue bélanger la plomberie 2001 est
bouché depuis trois mois on a
l'impression en fait que le le
propriétaire utilise ne fait que la
plomberie est défaillante pour me
pousser en dehors de mon logement
mélinda a finalement déposé une plainte
pour insalubrité auprès de la ville de
montréal la plomberie a été réparée en
24 heures quatre des six ménages de son
immeuble contestent leur éviction devant
la régie du logement
on est allé contesté à la régie
selon alain quand on doute que le
propriétaire veut vraiment faire ces
travaux là convoqué devant la régie le
propriétaire a été incapable de produire
les informations requises pour justifier
son projet il n'a pas retourné nos
messages les locataires attendent
toujours le jugement
pour la première fois de sa vie madame
rébillon c'est tout s'est tourné vers la
régie pour contester une hausse de loyer
de 4 et demi pour saint exigées par le
fonds de placement 4,8 aux édifices
étaient trop mais vous savez cette
compagnie avec des des investisseurs
dont ils en ont rien à [ __ ] de nous un
regard du tout
l'entreprise dit avoir investi 3
millions de dollars dans l'immeuble
depuis son acquisition pour expliquer
cette hausse
la régie l'a finalement réduite de plus
de la moitié
la régie du logement ignore combien
david deux reprises et des fictions sont
émis chaque année elle ignore aussi
combien s'avère justifiée quand on dit
que c'est une invitation à la fraude
c'est ça c'est que lui rien qu'ils
vérifient aucune vigilance
le taux élevé de présumées fraudes et de
malveillance mis au jour par l' enquête
du comité logement de la petite-patrie
signale un problème important avec un
marché en pleine ébullition
rien n'indique qu'ils soient sur le
point de se résorber
[Musique]